Every once in a while babies are born with
some organs on the outside instead of the
inside…
It’s sounds crazy but it’s TRUE and..
It’s happening more NOW than ever before.
Hey guys, what’s up- I’m Sapna here for
D-news.
About 1 out of every 2-thousand babies is
born with a deformity where their intestines
are outside their body.
This condition is called gastro-skee-sis ((gastroschisis)).
That’s from the greek word for belly-cleft.
Believe or not, many of these babies survive,
because soon after they’re born, surgeons
often perform a corrective procedure to place
the intestines back into the body.
But, that’s not always easy.
See, these organs are outside the skin and
are exposed to the elements, so they’re
usually inflamed and swollen!
And also, these infants have only developed
tiny bellies since they’re organs weren’t
inside.
-- That means the surgery is often done in
stages, one to ensure that they can get everything
back in and two to give the baby the best
possible chance for recovery.
Gastro-skee-sis occurs because some babies
are born with a hole right next to their belly
button.
And to understand why THAT happens, we have
to look at what is going on in the womb when
an embryo first develops an abdominal wall.
At about 3 and a half weeks… an embryo’s
digestive tract starts to form.
At 6 weeks, it starts to lengthen.
And by 10 weeks, the digestive tract and all
the major organs are encapsulated by the abdominal
cavity before the layers of the abdominal
wall seal everything off.
And THAT LAST PART is the stage when things
can go wrong…
There are a bunch of different theories about
exactly HOW things go wrong - but the majority
of scientists believe it's something called
the “vascular disruption theory.”
Essentially, it’s the idea that gastro-skee-sis
occurs because there’s not enough blood
flow to the abdominal layers.
The lack of blood supplying the abdominal
tissues as they form leaves a weak spot that
can end up rupturing.
This creates a hole right next to the fetus’s
umbilical cord.
And if that hole is BIG enough, the liver,
spleen and other organs CAN end up on the
exterior of the baby’s body also.
When all these organs end up on the outside,
it’s called an omphalocele and that occurs
in about 1 out of every 4000 births.
It’s also possible for the bladder- and
EVEN the heart - to end up on the outside
but that is much more rare.
What CAUSES these birth defects isn’t fully
understood yet...but we do have some clues.
Researchers think it could be genetic, and
they found it happens more often in YOUNG
mothers, women with poor nutrition, and women
who smoke, do drugs or consume alcohol.
And there's even research showing links to
aspirin intake and exposure to certain chemicals.
More research is obviously needed.
And the research can’t come soon enough.
A recent report from the c-d-c says the number
of babies born with gastroschisis - where
the intestines are outside - has been going
up around the world since the 1980’s.
According to the CDC...this is an urgent wakeup
call..
We NEED more answers!
If we know more about what causes it then
we can figure out how to stop it.
Have you ever wondered why some organs come
in pairs but others don’t?
To find out why click on this video!
And do you have any cool medical science questions
you want us to answer?
Tell me down in the comments section down
below.
Don’t forget to click subscribe we have
episodes of DNews for you every day!